yo what up brandon what up theo chin
nick chappelle cat i'm at work right now
big five sporting goods bowling alley
pro shop and i just want to know
is bowling a sport we are throwing that
hit a
15 pounds heaviest object in any sport
down the lane
hours on end is mowing a sport
king understand it for me gang gang buzz
balls baby
balls um it's a i think bolton is
definitely a sport man
i think the problem is it limits itself
in like how many different things you
can do
i wish the lane got a little more
different to where as the game went on
it kind of curved or they weren't
rocky yeah they just added in a small
speed bump or something
yeah or somebody dropped a um cert a
cert candy on a ramp or something do you
think golf is a sport
yeah i think golf is a sport i think
it's more for rich people
you know and a lot of like um
sometimes spousal abusers sure but
i think it is a sport and it's a good
sport man yeah i love bowling
yeah i think bowling though i don't know
if i think it's a sport i wish they
would
start to sport darts
or those hobbies i think it's got to be
something that gets your heart rate
going
you can make it competitive yeah you
gotta have your competitiveness like
sport competitive
experience it doesn't make it a sport
well that's a good question what makes
something a sport yeah
are video games a sport then those are
competitives
dancing a sport
i mean i did cheerleading that's a sport
i think a sport to me feels like
something where you compete against
someone else at the same exact
moment so like soccer each team can
score simultaneous at the same time
basketball baseball
curling yeah curling so maybe it's not a
sport well
here's the definition of a sport and
activity involving physical excursion
and skill in which an individual team
competes against another
so physical i don't really sweat when i
bowl i don't really sweat when i go it's
physical though i don't think so
how physical i heard someone i heard
someone say it's not a sport if you can
smoke a cigarette while doing it so golf
is out
that's a legit point nascar out uh
bowling out they could be
hobbies that have been turned into
competitions
yeah we're kind of like video games a
little bit yeah
because i wonder does bowling seem more
like an art
you know like a skill i don't know if i
would consider a sport though
[Music]